بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
يقول
يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى
يا ايها الذين امنوا اجتنبوا كثيرا من
الظن ان بعض الظن اثم
ولا تجسسوا ولا يغتب بعضكم بعضا
يحب احدكم ان ياكل لحم اخيه ميتا فكرهتموه
واتقوا الله ان الله تواب رحيم
وقوله تعالى واتقوا الله عقب هذه المناهي
تدل على ان من اخل بشيء من هذه
فقد اختلت تقواه لله سبحانه وتعالى
وداله السياق على انه لن يتم تقوى احدنا
مهما بلغ حتى
يتم
حتى يتم اعتماره بالمعروف
واعتماره
ما امر الله به والانتهاء عم نهى الله
سبحانه وتعالى عنه
فقوله تعالى واتقوا الله
واتقوا الله كما
عرفه العلماء هو اتخاذ وقايه التقوى
اتقي بالامر
اتقى بالفعل الماضي
ومن اتخاذ الوقايه الوقايه ما تقي
وتدرى عن
المتقى
ادرى عن المتقي هذا
الشر سواء كان من
كان من الحر او كان من اي شيء اي شيء يسمى
وقايه اذا كان
يقي صاحبه يقول تعالى
وسرابيل تقيكم الحر سرابيلا تقيكم باسكم
وفي الشرع في القران وفي السنه التقوى
تعريفه
ان يتخذ العبد وقايه من عذاب الله
فعلي اوامر
اوامر الله
واجتناب نواهي الله سبحانه وتعالى هذا
اسمه تقوى
فحينما يامر الله سبحانه وتعالى بتقواه او
بتقوى العذاب او تقوى يوم كذا وكذا وما
شابه ذلك
فان هذه المعاني كل كل اراجعه الى نفس
المعنى نفس الاداء وذلك ان يعتمر
العبد بما امر به وان ينتهي عما نهي عنه
ويكون بذلك قد اتقى
عذاب الله سبحانه وتعالى واتخذ وقايه
وقايه من تعذيب الله سبحانه وتعالى
وذلك لتمام عدل الله ان الله سبحانه
وتعالى عادل
ويقول ما يفعل الله بعذابك ومن شكرتم
وامنتم
التقوى
اذا امر الله سبحانه وتعالى بالتقوى فهو
امر بجميع
الاوامر في القران والانتهاء عن جميع
المناهي في القران وفي السنه بشكل عام
لكن اذا جاء في سياق مثل هذا فانه
بدلاله السياق وبالوضع في الجمله فانه يدل
على نوع من التخصيص
وهذا هو المفهوم من قوله يحب احدكم ان
ياكل لحم اخيه ميتا فكرهتم واتقوا الله
يعني
هذه هذا الغيبه هذه الغيبه
والتجسس
وسوء الظن الذي هو اثم وما شابه ذلك فان
هذه جميعا من ما يخل بطاق والعبد
فاذا لم ينتهي العبد عن هذه فانه
فانه قد جعل ظلمه في وقايته من عذاب الله
وقد يحيط به عذاب الله سبحانه وتعالى
وهذا مما يدل على ان هذه الذنوب من
الكبائر
لان الكبيره
الكبيره والصغيره هذا التعريف في معصيه
الله سبحانه وتعالى
فان هذا ورد في القران يقول سبحانه وتعالى
الذين يجتنبون
كبائر الفواحش
والفواحش الا اللمم اللمم يعني الصغائر
اللامام التي
تلتم فتصبح عظيمه لكنها تغفر
وكذلك قوله تعالى ان تجتنبوا كبائر ما
تنهون عنه نكفر عنكم سيئاتكم فاذا اجتنب
العبد كبائر ما ينهى ذلك على ان
تم صغائر وهذه الصغائر ما تعريفها وهذه
الكبائر ما تعريفها اختلف
التعريف بين العلماء من عالم الى عالم ومن
مذهب الى مذهب لكن
الراجح الذي
استقر عليه رايه الجمهور هو
ما كان من قول ابن عباس رضي الله عنهما
واختيار شيخ الاسلام
ان الكبيره
ماء
كان
تم عقاب
مخصوص له
ابيره ما خصص بعقاب ايش يعني يعني اما حد
في الدنيا او
يلعن صاحبه او له تسميه خاصه كالفاسق او
الفاجر او ما شابه ذلك او يسمى الفعل نفسه
بهذه التسميه
وكذلك اذا كان في
متوعد صاحبه
بعقاب خاص في الاخره فاي شيء يدخل في هذا
العموم فانه من كبائر الذنوب والصغائر ما
دون ذلك
يقول ان الله تواب رحيم
تواب
والذي
يتوب على عباده سبحانه وتعالى
وذلك انهما من تائب الا وتاب الله عليه
مرتين
فان الله تعالى يتوب عليه ليتوب ثم اذا
تاب ولقنه الله التوبه فانه يقبل هذه
التوبه عن عباده وكذلك
فانه سبحانه وتعالى هو الذي علم التوبه
اول مره
وقال سبحانه وتعالى فتلقى ادم من ربه
كلمات فتاب عليه ما هذه الكلمات قال تعالى
قال ربنا انا ظلمنا انفسنا وان لم تغفر
لنا وترحمنا لنكونن من الخاسرين هذه
الكلمات التي تلقاها ادم عليه السلام
واذا نظرنا الى الايه
يقول تعالى فتلقى ادم من ربه كلمات
وفي قراءه
فتلقى ادم من ربه كلمات
يعني ان الله سبحانه وتعالى لقنوا هذه
الكلمات
والهمه بها وعلمه اياها حتى تاب فبعد ان
تاب قبل الله سبحانه وتعالى توبته ومدحه
على هذه التوبه وهذا من عظيم توبه الله
سبحانه وتعالى على عباده فانه ليس فقط
يقبل التوبه عن عباده ويغفر السيئات بل هو
الذي يلهم العبد بالتوبه يلهمه التوبه
ويلقنه كيفيه التوبه ثم بعد ذلك يقبلها
منه
ويتوب عليه ثم يمدحه على هذه التوبه وهي
منه اول مره سبحانه وتعالى
وهذا من تمام معنى قول الله تعالى ان الله
تواب
تواب على وزن فعال والفعال
للمبالغه انه كثير التوبه على عباده
قال رحيم
رحيم
ورحمن
كلاهما
مشتق من الرحمه
والعلماء يقولون ان الرحمن الرحيم
اذين الاسمين
اذا
جاء في سياق واحد مقترنين
فان الرحمن يكون الصفه والرحيم يكون الفعل
واما اذا جاء الرحمن وحده عني به الرحيم
والرحمن واذا جاء الرحمن وحده عن به
الرحيم والرحمن فهذه من
انواع الكلمات
يعرفها العلماء فيقولون من الكلمات التي
ان اجتمعت افترقت يعني في المعنى
اجتمعت في نفس السياق افترقت في المعنى
واذا افترقت في السياق اتفقت في المعنى
اجتمعت في المعنى مثل ذلك الفقير والمسكين
والبر والتقوى والاسلام والايمان الامثله
كثيره
ويعرفها كثير منا فعلى كل حال الرحمن
الرحيم اذا جاء
الرحمن واسم الرحمن واسم الرحيم في نفس
السياق مثل فاتحه الكتاب بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
عني بالرحمن صفه الله سبحانه وتعالى وصفه
بالرحمه الواسعه
والرحيم
فعله بانه يوصل هذه الرحمه الى عباده
ويرحم بها فلذلك يقول بعض العلماء يقول
الرحمن ذو الرحمه الواسعه والرحيم ذو
الرحمه الواصله هكذا
واذا جاء الرحمن وحده او جاء رحيم وحده
فانه يعنى هذا وهذا ويتناول هذين المعنيين
فقوله تعالى ان الله تواب رحيم
هذا يعم رحمه الله سبحانه وتعالى بين
العباد في هذا وفي غيره وجميع ما تضمنه
اسم الرحمن فانه مقصود هنا
وكذلك رحيم بعباده حيث يمهلهم هو تواب لمن
تاب منهم رحيم
فان كثيرا منهم لم يتوب والله عز وجل لا
يفاجعوهم
بالمؤاخذه سبحانه وتعالى بل يعفو عنهم
ويمهلهم الى غير ذلك من
الاوصاف التي التي هي
متضمنه متضمنه في هذين الاسمين العظيمين
ان الله تواب رحيم ينبغي علينا ان
نلاحظ شيئا في اسماء الله سبحانه وتعالى
وصفاته ابن القيم رحمه الله
فانه
قسم ما
يطلق
على الله سبحانه وتعالى
اخبارا او اسما او صفه او ما شابه ذلك الى
سته اقسام
لكن الذي يهمنا من هذه التقسيمات
انه ان الله سبحانه وتعالى له الاسم
المفرد
ثم له
الاسم المفرد ثم له الاسم المفرد اذا جمع
وضم الى اسم مفرد او الى اسماء اخرى يعني
قوله تعالى ان الله تواب وحده له معنى
ورحيم ان الله رحيم له معنى وان الله تواب
رحيم له معنى خاص
[Silence]
فالفقه الاكبر والذي يرتكز عليه نجاه
العبد والذي ينجى به العبد فانه ما انطوى
عليه قلبه
وسريرته من الظن بالله سبحانه وتعالى
واليقين
وما
اضافه الى الله واثبته لله وما نفاه عن
الله سبحانه وتعالى وبهذا يزداد الايمان
وبهذا
ينقص النفاق والكفر
والايمان
يجر معه الى قلب صاحبه والى قلب المخلص
فانه يجر معه
الطاعه لله سبحانه وتعالى الظاهره لذلك
فان العلماء يقولون فقه اكبر وفقه اصغر
فان الفقه الاصغر لا ينفع دون الاكبر
فانه لا ينفع دون الاكبر يقول تعالى يا
ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا ان اكرمكم
عند الله اتقاكم ان الله عليم خبير هذه
مساله
التساوي بين العباد بين البشر بين
البني ادم بين اولاد ادم عليه السلام
هذه مساله مهمه ان نفهمها
ونفهم الفرق بين التفضيل
والمفاضل بين
الافراد والمفاضله بين الاجناس في فرق
وهذه الايه تتناول احداهما دون الاخر
والله عز وجل صدر هذا بقوله يا ايها الناس
والناس هذه الكلمه اصلها من اناس اناس
مثل
الشر مثلا كلمه الشر الشر اصل هذه الكلمه
في اللغه الاشهر هكذا لكن العرب في لغتهم
يسخطون الهمزه لانهم يرون انها في درج
الكلام
يسهلون اللفظ فيقولون بدل الاشهر الاشهر
الاشهر لانه يكثر هذا اللفظ فان الناس
فانهم يسقطون الهمزه فيقولون الشر الشر
ماشي
ويضاعفون الشين وكذلك الخير
الاصل فيه الاخير
الاخير هذا اصله لكن لكثره الاستعمال
اسقطوا الهمزه
فصار الخير كذلك الله الله هذه اللفظه
فان الاصل انها الاله الاله الاله الاله
اقسم بالاله كثر استعمال هذه الكلمه
فالعرب في درج الكلام اسقطوا هذه الهمزه
تخفيفا لكثره الاستعمال هكذا يقول علماء
الصرف وعلماء اللغه فيكون
النتيجه الله
نفس الشيء هنا الناس الناس
اصله الاناس
اناس
وهو ماخوذ من الانس والانس
ما
يتضمن هذا المعنى من الاستئناس
والتمدد فان
والجماع فان الانس يقولون الانسان بطبعه
اجتماعي ولذلك لا تجد انسانا
منعزلا منزويا وحده الا لعله هذا طارق ليس
هذا الاصل الاصل ان الناس واجتمعون
الانسان
اجتماعي في اصل
خلقته
وسمي
انسانا
كان الجمع الجنسي الناس
والاشتقاق يعود الى الانس يعني انه يستانس
مع غيره
وقيل انه مشتاق من النسيان
لانه كثير النسيان والجحود
وهذا وان كان اضعف لكنه قال به بعض
العلماء ولا مانع ان يكون ماخوذا من هذا
وهذا لانه صحيح
واجتماعي بطبعه ماخوذ من الانس
والاناث وكذلك هو
جاحد وظلوم في اصل طبعه
وماخوذ من النسيان وان كان هذا ابعد على
كل حال كلمه الناس
الناس
فان هذه الكلمه
ليس لها مفرده
الناس
والانسان
الكلمه مش نفس البنيه ولا هي نفس
فقوله تعالى يا ايها الناس
العلماء يختلفون في التفسير ما المقصود
بكلمه الناس في القران يعني يقول الله يا
ايها الناس حين نزول هذه الايه من كان
يقصد الله سبحانه وتعالى بهذا
يعني لما قال الله سبحانه وتعالى
يا ايها الناس واعبدوا ربكم من كان
المقصود بهذا الامر
لذلك تجد اتجاهات ومشارب المفسرين مختلفه
بعضهم يقول يعني يا اهل مكه
ان احين نزول هذه من كان الناس مخاطبون
بهذه الايه اهل مكه فكان يا ايها الناس
يعني يا اهل مكه
وقد يكون
المقصود يا ايها الناس المؤمنين قد يكون
المقصود على حسب السياق لكن
الاشمل
والاعم
ان جميع من يدخل في هذا المعنى
حتى الجن وادخله كثير من العلماء قالوا
الناس غير الانسان اذا قال الله يا ايها
الانسان يختلف عن يا ايها الناس يا ايها
الناس للجن والانس
الناس
الجن ناس
والانس ناس
على كل حال
يقول تعالى يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم
فهذا يدل على اتحاد
اتحاد الخالق من ذكر وانثى وهذا يدل على
اتحاد الاصل
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل
لتعارفوا اللام هنا للتعليل
يعني لاي عله لاي سبب
دام يقولون للتعليل يعني سببيه يعني ما هي
الغايه
وما خلقت الجن والانس الا ليعبدون هذه
اللام هذه تسمى لام لام التعليل ما هذه
اللام اللام
التعليل يعني لاي عله خلقنا هكذا من
مصارف مختلفه لكننا نعود الى اصل واحد
والى خالق واحد
ونعود الى
اصل واحد ونعود الى
اصل في الفعل واحد يعني ما من انسان الا
وهو مخلوق من ذكر وانثى
غير هيك عندنا يعني ادم عليه السلام وحواء
وعيسى بن مريم وبس والباقي كلهم ايش من
ذكر وانثى
فالطريقه طريقه الخلق نفس الطريقه
والخالق نفس الخالق والاصل نفس الاصل طيب
اذا لماذا اختلفت
الناس
واصبحت
واصبح البشريه اجناسا قال لتعارفوا شعوبا
وقبائل لتعارفوا
اصل هذه الكلمه
لتتعارفوا لكن اسقطت التاء
للتخفيف يعني من اجل ان تعرفوا انسابكم من
اجل ان تعرفوا
وتلاحظوا اصولكم بس
الواحد يعرف قرابته مين
ويعرف كيف
ينظم الامور
وان تعرف على غيره عرفه اصله وعرف بلده بس
هذا هذا هو السبب الوحيد
هكذا يقول يقول لي تعارفوا يعني الغايه في
ذلك فقط
فقط وسياتي علينا غدا ان شاء الله لمن
نقول فقط لكن فقط من اجل ان نتعارف نعرف
الواحد منا الاخر بس هذا هو السبب
وما سوى ذلك من التفاخر بالانساب والاجناس
فهذه كلها
اخراج لهذا على غير المخرج الذي اراد الله
سبحانه وتعالى
وسياتي الكلام على ذلك غدا باذن الله الله
اعلم صلى الله عليه وسلم على نبينا محمد